Bila espessa além de dieta tem
suplementos que podem ajudar então a
Bila espessa ou viscosa é um sintoma de
várias condições incluindo problemas de
fígado vesícula biliar ou ductos
biliares então vamos orientar aqui vocês
sobre o que fazer além de ter uma dieta
adequada começando pela dieta uma dieta
rica em frutas vegetais grãos integrais
gorduras saudáveis e proteínas pode
ajudar a manter a b fluida então
alimentos ricos em fibras como aveia
frutas legumes também são benéficos
beber bastante água essencial para
manter a bile fluida e os suplementos
podemos falar de vários né o ômega-3 o
óleo de peixe ele vai ajudar a reduzir a
inflamação melhorar a saúde do fígado e
melhorar a saúde também da vesícula
biliar a vitamina E ela atua como
antioxidante ela ajuda a proteger as
células do fígado e da vesícula biliar
especialmente tooc trian que é essa
família específica de vitamina E o
magnésio ele pode ajudar a relaxar os
músculos da vesícula biliar e ducos
biliares facilitando a fluidez da bile e
tem um suplemento chamado del limoneno
que é encontrado em óleos cítricos ele
ajuda a dissolver cálculos biliares e
melhorar a fluidez da bile também a
betaína nidra né O trimetilglicina que é
encontrado em alimentos como beterraba
pode ajudar a dissolver a Bil e prevenir
a formação de cálculos biliares também
probióticos manté uma boa saúde
intestinal com esses probióticos pode de
forma indireta ajudar na produção e
fluidez da bile pois a saúde intestinal
está relacionada a saúde do fígado e da
vesícula biliar então você pode ter
várias abordagens naturais integrativas
por exemplo drenagem hepática existe
algumas terapias naturais como a
drenagem hepática com chá de dente de
leão ou com o a silimarina né retirada
do Milk fistal né podem ajudar a limpar
e proteger o fígado que pode refletir
positivamente na produção de b e tem
técnicas de massagem abdominal que pode
estimular a vesícula biliar a melhorar a
fluidez da B